one
to go
hello folks welcome to rational science
hi guys directly from Frankfurt Germany
and uh we have a great day today
hopefully uh we're gonna be talking
about existence what is existence
and uh uh probably the most important
word in physics so today's a that object
was uh it kind of yeah there's you know
they're running side by side there we're
going to have our um science critic
we're gonna be discussing something
about accuracy of
predictions accuracy of predictions yeah
we'll get to that anyways and at the end
we're going to open up the floor for
questions and uh let's start with a
subject that was left over from the
other day or that apparently some people
had a little bit of interest in and that
is what is our natural diet now I want
to get the question right yeah yeah
because some people sorry I'm in the
wrong class yeah well this file was uh
suggesting that vegan or vegetarianism
or whatever uh is our natural diet right
that's what he was suggesting and I just
want to focus on the question because
some people answer the wrong questions
they go out there and they say look I
think this you should eat this because
it's healthier or whatever you know and
and that's not the question the question
is what is our natural diet so let's try
to focus on the question and not get
into politics and opinions and you know
a religion okay so here's the question
is this fell put it the other day he
says the best way to get your health
back is to go to your what natural diet
raw vegan diet okay that's what he
recommended and that's what he thinks
our natural diet is okay so that's that
was our starting point now one fellow
did not answer that question answered
another question I'm going to put it
anyways because of uh it's a bad example
no no because of an issue that he raised
I think we should touch upon and the
fellow said the following okay uh there
we go says eat everything Raw
okay when you cook food you destroy
ingredients and they practically turn
into garbage blah blah blah okay there
is a lot of oxygen in the blood so we do
not despise blood it is life great blood
and you'll be uh
enriched with additional oxygen etc etc
okay so he recommended that uh you eat
raw food okay
and
um or the spiky canines to tear the heck
out of apples you know that's the
subject I I found out this week as well
you know we got canine you know uh
unlike other animals that don't have
them and we'll get to that in a second
here but uh this is the issue here uh
that uh I wanted to answer for this
fellow okay natural diet any food for
the day whenever we find
it's Kentucky and fried chicken still uh
open
okay so this is uh something that I just
want to point out to this fellow a
number of sites with good evidence of
fire per 10 000 years went out there and
looked at all the uh sites that we found
to date that uh show absolute proof or
evidence of fire and before 400 000
years ago uh there were we have no sites
there are no sites that we can really
put our you know hand in the fire for uh
the fire kind of you know controlled
fire here we're talking about okay
control fire because fires uh I'm sure
uh you know our ancestors Homo erectus
and Beyond probably saw fire they
probably had forest fires and who knows
what but controlled fire okay when they
say cooking we're talking about from 400
000 years onwards okay and you can see
here the number of sites with good
evidence of fire uh the years in which
these sites are found and you can see
that more and more sites are found as we
get to the present that's to be expected
because obviously the farther back in
time you go the harder it is to show you
know uh that there was a fire that
doesn't mean that it wasn't there it
just means it's hard to show okay so
those are the uh in general terms uh
more or less so that you can get a
ballpark figure on when we had control
fire yeah we're talking about cooking
here okay cooking Meats uh before then
uh well maybe there was a time where
they cooked and we don't have evidence
and before then we were just eating
everything raw apparently okay now
that's the general picture take it for
what it what you want okay so the
question is back to square one you know
what is our natural diet how do I want
to get to that question well I want to
look at the evolution of man for those
people who believe in evolution right
even about the Bible says uh that you
know the animals were made for man so he
could you know kill them and eat them
but that's a separate story but uh here
you have the situation where you say
well you know what was our Evolution
like how did we evolve as
humans did we evolve as
um Predators were we carnivores where we
uh vegetarians vegans or whatever or
were we omnivores which is another issue
and that's the issue a couple people
raised here here we see it one Paul says
human beings are omnivores we need meat
and veggies based on a study of ancient
humans skeletons the ideal is about 60
animal and again goes into you know what
is healthy and so on we don't care about
the healthy part we just want to know
you know what is the evolution of of our
stomachs you could say right now the
fella also says we are omnivores and
another fella says humans evolve this
carnivores hahaha you didn't like that
at all and he says hunting and Gathering
omnivorous diets began at the same time
now my point uh last time was that you
know those Spears they were not used to
hunt apples or pumpkins okay uh they
were used to hunt animals and probably
defend themselves against other animals
but the animals that had the Apple in
their mouths
in other words you know uh I think for
the most part we were carnivores okay
for the most part you think it's mostly
and you'd say 60 40 like the thing said
okay let's get into that uh are we
omnivores are we vegetarians are we
carnivores which one are we I think
anyone would say we're omnivores I mean
here's a here's a question yeah and a
cow digests meat okay can a lion digest
uh lettuce and and that's because that's
their evolution now we can eat both
right yeah stands the reason that we're
omnivores okay but the definition is
that how we started because now we're
talking about millions of years what is
our history that's what we're looking at
that's what I'm gonna go into in a
second here okay so it is is eating
habit specialization
or opportunity
uh how we evolve we just uh what I mean
is our spotted that Niche are all
animals omnivores when they start their
species and then they specialize into
carnivorism and then forget one at the
other or is it the other way around that
they start as a carnivore or a herbivore
and grow into an omnip well let's find
out because man is gonna answer man's
gonna answer that question okay let's
look at man okay here we have humans
okay more or less now you don't have to
believe exactly that this is what
happened these are assumptions okay in
general this is our you could say state
of the art knowledge uh we came from
some kind of monkey okay we'll call them
Australopithecus uh we went through Homo
habilis a man who started using tool or
some uh human-like creature some hominin
right uh Homo erectus you see the dates
there at the top then we went to
rhodesiansis in Africa in Europe he was
called Heidelberg okay more or less
that's the same stage and then we ended
up about maybe 200 to 300 000 years ago
with Homo sapiens sapiens which is what
we are today okay so that's more or less
the the uh Evolution okay the the big
picture
um uh fire I put it on uh modern human
but you could say maybe up to four
hundred thousand maybe even rhodosiensis
and
um Heidelberg they probably used fire
okay in other words controlled fire this
is the general picture okay now that's
what I'm gonna use as an assumption okay
now as you can see here we started out
as
um
we started out with as herbivores and
fruit fruit divorce you know we we
um we ate fruits and veggies at the
beginning perhaps and maybe uh took
advantage of some Kill by some other
animal and started eating meat and
that's how we became omnivores uh you
already have this uh in individual this
uh Proto hominid you could say
Australopithecus and he he was already
an omnivore towards the end of his
existence
and in other words he went from
herbivore to omnivore uh Homo habilis
was also both an omnivore uh you know he
ate both veggies and meat uh probably
took advantage of kills out there and
lost the ability to climb trees like
other monkeys can do today why because
you probably felt uh more uh or safe
enough to be you know on the planes
and as you move along you go to Homo
erectus he he was a hunter he was a meat
eater and this fellow lasted for the
Latin next two million years if if we
count all the way to us and assuming we
evolved from erectus right
um so we're talking about you know uh a
meat eater here he's a carnivore he's a
point actually okay and then and then
let me finish now then we have a Rhoda
ziensis and again he starts about maybe
800 000 years ago he evolves from her
rectus and again we're talking about
Heidelberg here in Europe and both of
them you know they were meat eaters the
net meat eaters in fact uh Neanderthal
who descends from Heidelberg is
considered to have eaten 99 of his diet
uh being meat it was probably a hundred
percent I don't know if he ate any nuts
or berries or any other thing
um and eventually we ended up with our
uh humans today and what are we well
we're moving from carnivore to omnivore
I'm back again
and it seems to be a consensus in the
chat that no they keep that there okay
it seems to be consensus that we're
always omnivores in fact there's even
comments that are saying what I was
about to say how we haven't been we
always we weren't always the best at
hunting we were kind of more prey so we
didn't really we couldn't really rely on
eating meat because we were so good at
hunting but as you become more and more
of the dominant species the the what do
you call apex predator
allows you to be a carnivore yeah and
and that's really the point here the
point is that even though Homo erectus
and rhodesiansis were uh omnivores to
some degree I I can't say that they were
full you know 100 carnivores uh the
amount of veggies that they ate or
fruits or whatever uh was a very small
part of their diet and that's what I'm
gonna get to next and one of the ways we
can show this is looking at neanderthals
okay here we have the diet of
Neanderthals okay and this is what they
came up with they said look uh
neanderthals ate about 70 percent of
what they ate was Mammoth they loved to
hunt Mammoth on the other hand uh in
comparison to uh hyenas uh they
apparently chased after horses they they
loved the the Run whereas the
Neanderthals love the Close Quarters
fighting against the mammoth uh and you
can see the the black lines there those
represent the Neanderthals the white
ones represent the uh hyenas uh this is
one study okay and it shows that
neanderthals really like to eat quite a
bit of meat and I did uh see a article
once uh I don't have the reference or
anything but it said 99 of uh
Neanderthal diet because of you know
when they did the analysis of their
bones They concluded was 99 of their
diet was meat
I have to assume that is an apex
predator humans were perhaps at the same
level at least as long as Homo erectus
and
um Rhoda ziensis were around uh we're
talking about anywhere from 2 million to
about maybe 300 000 years ago during
that period of time
you know you're talking almost two
million years we were primarily
carnivores okay and that's where we you
know uh developed our vampire yeah
yeah I mean that shows you that we're
not if you look at the teeth of uh you
know uh animals who are uh like cows and
whatever yeah they're all flat so they
don't have that do you think we have
canines do you think we dream what the
animal lived
in his life when we eat them if we eat a
deer brain do we dream the the deer's
like I do sometimes yeah
okay so uh but for this you need to look
at a little bit of the Neanderthal
Evolution and uh I I made this map it's
in my book uh on the Neanderthal book
and it's the homo erectus Empire uh
these are just big pictures okay in
other words very very general and some
of the dates uh have to do with some of
the fines they had out there and all I
want to show here is that homo erectus
started originally in Africa and moved
up to Asia and also to Europe and by
about 800 000 years ago he ends up in
England Mary old England okay that's the
only thing I want to show that homo
erectus already had gone as far as
England and what you need to understand
here and uh you know where we got that
information and here we have it okay
give me a second here this is England uh
about 800 000 years ago to about 220 000
years ago it it was United to France to
the continent there was no English
Channel and so all these monkeys you
know could be uh erectus could be
antecessor which was found Northern in
Northern Spain could be
um uh Heidelberg you know because you're
talking about 800 000 years ago it could
be any of those some kind of creature at
that level and they lived in that uh you
could say Northwestern part of France
which uh United with England about 220
000 years ago the English Channel was
created and uh those tribes Clans
whatever those people that were stuck in
England eventually died off and all we
have from them is these sites that you
can see there uh Peck field and um box
Grove and so on and you you'll see some
of the dates there like habisberg is 800
000 years ago and they found flakes they
found uh footprints okay and so we we
think that there were human like
hominids living in that region okay
uh and the question is you can see the
Glaciers are in other words the the
settlements the sites that we found are
all along the glacier that was extending
All the Way South into England
and so the question is how did these
monkeys live did they have clothes
you know uh they uh matter of they're
freezing their asses off well you would
think so but that's not the case I think
so uh
see uh does uh does the wolf uh put a
coat on does the polar bear uh use uh
you know he also brought his own yeah we
had also a woolly rhinoceros that
eventually became extinct uh Woolly
Mammoth you know so all these animals
they lived in the north and how about
the woolly man
you know that's what these people were
uh if if
um I mean if uh Homo erectus did not
control fire
we could assume that they did towards
the end of their reign but certainly not
at the beginning and we find them 800
000 years ago in England next to the
glaciers you would have to assume that
this animal this hominid he was a nude
he had no clothes so the question well
yeah if he didn't have clothes but
that's like he had no shoes he was
stepping on the snow etc etc et cetera
et cetera to think about it it's like a
wolf the Wolves sleep in the snow and
you say how can a dog sleep in this
really man have been a better name for
them maybe maybe true but then you would
have several woolly men from you know
erectus Heidelberg you know I mean
there's still people we know who are
very Woolly and hair on their backs
they're known as Armenians
they can make it through the winter no
problem
okay so here are the Neanderthal sites
uh the official one is the one that you
see the long one there the big uh train
tracks I put the red line there because
I don't think that the ones on the east
side are Neanderthals especially not the
ones in Israel you know I don't think
there were any Jewish neanderthals okay
riding camels uh Neanderthal was an
animal or a hominid that lived in cold
weathers not in in the hot weathers I
don't think nanothal ventured South so
you know I disagree with that map that
they put out there showing that Nando
Falls extended all the way to Israel and
I do argue and I think with good reason
that uh several analysts I'm not I'm not
an anonymous of Bones I just read what
they wrote okay and what they wrote is
that the Neanderthals the alleged
so-called neanderthals of shannedar in
Iraq and some of the others in Israel
are notably different than the classical
Western Neanderthal of Germany Spain and
France and so they've noticed
differences and that's why I'm saying
that maybe we're not talking about the
same creatures or the same Clans I don't
think they were neanderthals uh some
other creature that was there
okay but the point here is the following
here we have uh the Neanderthals that
was probably their Last Stand they made
in southern France and probably most of
Spain especially uh down south in
Gibraltar okay maybe that's where they
made their Last Stand
um
a couple people argue for that I I more
or less agree with them I think that's
probably where we'll find the last or
the more uh the latest neanderthals
right and this is in general terms uh
the path of humans
um we started as rhodesians uh homo
rhodesiansis way down south now the
itinerary there is not to be taken
literally in other words what we're what
I'm showing there is simply that there
was a movement of uh humans from Africa
into Europe and arrived in Europe maybe
around 40 000 maybe 35 000 years ago and
I'm saying by that time the Neanderthals
were gone but the end of those two
things uh first
um they didn't wear clothes didn't have
any need for clothes because they had an
evolution from heidelbergs and before
them from antecessor before then from
erectus all of which already lived in
cold climates second I think uh 99 of
their diet was meat and I think humans
were at that time at the same level we
were primarily meat eaters did we eat
veggies probably did so but maybe
veggies was a very very small part of
our diet in general what we ate where it
was meat and I think that's what we use
the spears for to kill animals okay live
one more day okay so uh here's a study
this is a modern day study of
um
Hunter gathers that are still around
today okay but keep in mind we're
talking about hunter-gatherers of today
uh they're not so Hunter no not so much
gathers as you know you're talking about
they gather more corpses well you can't
compare them against uh the p
okay this is the I guess one of the
charts there and it shows that
approximately 70 to 75 of the of these
modern day right
um hunter-gatherers is primarily meat
and there's only about maybe 25 to 30
percent which is veggies and uh maybe
fruits uh non-meats okay that's the
general picture but again uh the author
of that uh sister here uh cordain and uh
he said the diets of modern day
hunter-gatherers okay so he makes that
uh clear okay and consumed high amounts
of animal food okay again we're talking
about today right uh most 75 percent of
worldwide hunter gatherers societies
derive greater than 50 of their
subsistence from animal Foods whereas
only 14 of these societies derived
greater than 50 percent of their
subsistence from uh gathered plant Foods
okay but again uh we're talking about
modern day and not how we evolved okay
um
this is uh there's another way of
showing uh where we stand today are we
omnivores absolutely in fact we can
almost call ourselves vegetarians and
not carnivores anymore here are the
numbers okay this these are the uh tons
of meat produced and sold in the world
today I think this is an objective uh
statistic okay 300 million 340 million
tons of meat that's how much we produced
in 2018 the numbers have changed
relatively little to today okay
in contrast we have two billion tons of
grains and one billion uh tons of
veggies pretty sure that has to do with
the economy uh well the point here is
that we produce this some of it goes to
feeding animals but the point here is
that you have a ten to one ratio between
veggies if we lump them all together
right veggies and uh Meats there's a 10
to 1 ratio that's how much we consume on
Earth and so ten thousand one it's a ten
to one it's a 340 million
to 2 billion and one billion well two
billion grains one billion veggies a
little more whatever but it's a ten to
one ratio you have three billion versus
300 million so you have a 10 to 1 ratio
we are essentially
um vegetarians today we've gone back to
being omnivores but more on the veggie
side and I think that if you go back to
those millions of years in which maybe
two millionaires uh in which humans
evolved and we evolved our fangs right
now use them to chew rice yeah
I think we we evolved our guts and
everything to eat meat originally so but
now we're changing that and going back
to veggies where did we start that with
the Agricultural Revolution we're
talking about the Neolithic maybe 10 15
000 years ago maybe a little more we
started eating veggies again and more
practical I guess well not only that
it's that you can feed more people or
produce it's more efficient to feed
people with you know uh it's peasant
food Purina manchao
and that is uh to feed them with me
okay so let's move on here we're gonna
look at um
uh what is it the our Extinction segment
very quickly here got relatively little
to show today but here it goes uh first
one is the world population bomb might
not go off after all and the other day
we passed the 8 billion Mark November 15
of last year uh we passed the 8 billion
Mark according to one study by the
United Nations and the the Maghrib verse
had a peak inside of 10.4 billion around
the year 2080. but a new report parallel
report says that that may not be true
says if economic development continues
at the current Pace the report still
finds that population growth could Peak
at 8.6 billion in 2050 and fall below 8
billion by 2100 in other words uh we're
going to Peak mid-century and then it's
going to be all the way down that's what
they're saying and they're not scared
about and fall below 8 billion doesn't
scare anybody yeah that's when
a lot of these people are
environmentalists or conservationists
and they're looking at the environment
and saying we're destroying the
environment the fewer people the better
and so when it comes down they say
that's good news and the question is
that good news maybe it is for the
environment is it good for the economy
that's another issue but I I I Circle
here this other part which I thought was
amusing because they still haven't
gotten a handle on why we're not having
children education and economic progress
have reliably reduced fertility rates in
the past as economic conditions improve
for more women especially in developing
countries with the highest fertility
rates they will have fewer children and
lead to a quicker decline in global
population and again these people have
no clue whatsoever no it's got nothing
to do with education
they're saying educated women make less
kids yeah and I've shown in the past I'm
not going to do that again uh but that
in the 19th century was the rich people
who had lots of children and I've gotten
lots of pictures on that and people
can't get their minds wrapped around
that because we always put lots of
children poor women and that's not that
wasn't the case in the 19th century
that's one issue but there's another
issue in that said and I'll tell you a
little anecdote and that'll put in the
right perspective I was at a house where
they had a servant a woman and she was
severely uneducated I mean she she was
just a person who was looking for a job
in the city and she had a boy and she
would bring the boy with her to the
house and while she did the chores and
so I asked her if that was her only kid
she said yeah and I asked her if
um if she was going to have more and she
told me a little story she said said you
know my father in in our little town he
had like four or five six girlfriends
and with each one hand like five to
eight kids so you know half the town
looked like her because there were like
50 or 60 children that came from the
same father and all these women just had
children with him dude's got a lot of
alimony to pay yeah but it turns out she
comes to the city she has this kid and I
said so how many more are you gonna have
just no
gonna have another one
I said why not says no I gotta work and
I can't uh I can barely stay alive as it
is you know with what I make etc etc and
this was an ignorant woman
you know and not educated and she
already knew
you know from her own skin her own
experience that she was not supposed to
have another kid in fact the one she had
probably was a mistake
and so uh here's the rule okay it's got
nothing to do with education
which is what these people are saying
it's got to do with your urbanization
you come to the city you stop having
children it's City Life that kills
children
cities are
period so whenever is all these people
say well we don't know why population is
declining or we're not having children
Etc it's because you come to the city
when you come to the city children's
time I mean there's more to it but
you're not going to go into it right
right but I mean that's the big picture
you're making it sound like Voodoo the
cities make you sterile as soon as you
cross the highway ah my balls shrink no
okay here's another oh
it's getting I need a better system than
that but Jesus Christ there he goes okay
uh EU Chief calls for muscular policy to
counter China's alternative world order
we have a new world order but it's not
the one you were thinking of it's the
Chinese New World Order and this is uh
uh Ursula Van Der Leiden Lyon and she
says uh China is pursuing a systemic
change of the international order okay
and so she recommends she had a talk the
other day restricting European companies
investments in what robotics uh Quantum
Computing artificial intelligence you
know technology high technology they
don't want to give the Chinese all that
technology because they're going to use
it to what to change the world order and
uh apparently according to Lion she says
an alternative vision of the world order
and whatever she's referring to the
communism Communist Party of China okay
so she's a little worried about the
power that the Chinese are grabbing you
know the influence that's one issue and
the other one is the fact that you know
here they are
um influencing countries with their
money the other day they convinced
Honduras to cut relations with Taiwan
and now uh Honduras instead goes with
mainland China recognizes China is the
only China and so on you know so their
Chinese or Mainland Chinese right the
Communists are buying people off with
money and that's what worries people
like uh Ursula because he says oh what
what they're doing is changing the world
order
the world order that she has in mind
obviously versus the one in communist
countries see not the only one here we
have uh Mr Millie he's the uh uh
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and he he went with his little cup to
ask for money from Congress the other
day see if they would contribute to his
budget 2024 budget and obviously he had
to paint China as a big monster uh in
fact
um I guess the pitch was more or less
like you know look I've got a pop gun
and uh General Lee on the other side who
is the chairman of the Joint Chiefs in
China he's got a Kalashnikov he's got an
AK-47 against my pop gun so please give
me more money so that these people don't
either catch up or surpass us and so
Millie suggested the phone says they
have a rational goal to be a global the
the global right uh co-equal with the
United States and Superior militarily by
mid-century and he says we have to
outpace that and that will assure what
the peace peace through strength if I
have the biggest gun we have peace but
two people have the biggest size guys
yeah so he went with his little Cub his
little hat asking for donations you know
and uh but just for your information he
wants a trillion dollars and that's up
from 800 billion so he's asking for a
quarter increase
in the defense budget so keep that in
mind where's that money coming from from
God from Heaven you know someone's got
to pay for that for that those expenses
that's why you know the congressman they
listen carefully what do you have to
offer well you know what I have to offer
you is scare uh be scared of the Chinese
because they're going to take over and
that's the buzzword out there today you
know everybody's scared of the Chinese
the yellow the yellow fear it's called
the yellow fear not the fever but the
fear
the yellow fever was in 1970 this is the
yellow fear okay okay but is that uh
warranted and I say it ain't okay and
here's why it ain't okay
Chinese manufacturing slows in marched
Services growth hits 12-year High what's
happening what's growing in China is
Services okay there's the expansion of
the service sector uh what is that
that's travel entertainment Leisure
Services you know video games Tick Tock
uh all that nonsense uh you know what I
call unemployment okay and uh says that
Beijing has set an economic growth
Target of around five percent for this
year one of its lowest in decades but
Lee the minister the economic Mister
Minister has warned it will not be easy
to reach that goal so China is having
economic problems why because it turned
the corner uh what was it in 2015 it
became for the first time a service
economy where Services surpassed for the
first time in GDP manufacturing now not
only do you have that you have also
labor
uh Chinese labor now is mostly services
and growing what's uh being uh Left
Behind is manufacturing especially if
you have people like good old Ursula who
says that they're not going to sell any
more high technology to China so that it
doesn't accomplish its goal of imposing
its version of the new world order right
and so I think China's
um turned a corner it's reached a Zenith
right it'll keep Rising but what I'm
saying is becoming asymptotic it's
growth the country that's growing now is
India why because India was so far back
so underdeveloped that now with the
technology available out there it can
grow at a faster rate but it will also
hit a plateau turn the corner and become
asymptotic and so what happens with when
all the countries in the world become
asymptotic in their growth
then I want to see what happens and
if we throw on top of that the fact that
population is also going to turn the
corner now we all go see right now the
roller coaster is getting to the top and
I think it's going to be exponential
it's scary I was watching a bunch of
videos about how I mean I told you how
also women aren't having kids this is
becoming more and more apparent to
everyone yeah
and that on top of all this is just it
becomes clear that 20 years from now is
going to be a very different world very
old world very uh uneconomic world
what's this BS about 20 years I mean
assuming assuming we get that far this
is gonna get real dystopia real fast
yeah what I think is going to happen is
um there's gonna be an economic crisis
and when not if but when that happens uh
the question is you know will money have
any value will anybody want money uh
what would be the reason to accept money
if nobody else will accept it you can't
unload it onto someone else because they
don't want it so why will you want it
and if you don't want it we have a
problem because nobody will collect
salaries and nobody collects salaries
nobody works and if nobody works we
don't produce food forget about all the
other stuff the uh what is it Leisure
and uh vacations all that stuff uh food
is what we need to be alive and so I I
say when if but when the economic crisis
hits what I mean by that money will be
no more
okay and just in case uh just to make
your day
uh in an upbeat uh direction right take
it into a beat here we have another
problem the top Economist Mohamed El
Aryan uh warns that erosion and Trust
caused by banking crisis will lead to
economic contagion and we had uh the
second and the third biggest bank
failures in U.S history the other day
just a week ago and they're only they
were only beat by the one in 2008 with
the housing crisis okay it's a Silicone
Valley Bank from California in the
Signature Bank of New York they fell
apart they uh declared bankruptcy okay
and that was a big blow
um but did it stop there I know you had
the credit Swiss uh Bank there uh taken
over by USB and just in case the
Deutsche Bank is also in trouble says
after Silicon Valley Bank became the
second largest bank of all time to fail
investors and analysts across the world
have been sounding alarm Bells some fear
that the entire banking system is still
at risk but many think that the treasury
Department's decision to what to bail
out depositors uh-huh so that means uh
now we have the taxpayer bailing out
those people who put more than 250 000
in their account right was enough to
solve the problem the crisis raised
concerns about the stability of all
major Banks but Deutsche Bank one of the
world's largest and most scrutinized
financial institutions is worrying
investors more than others Deutsche Bank
was already not in the best shape when
the recent banking crisis started the
German banking giant has faced numerous
challenges in recent years with its
stock price dropping about 30 percent in
less than two months despite a small
recent rebound investors remain
skeptical about the bank's future
prospects moreover Deutsche Bank
Deutsche bank's interconnectedness with
other financial institutions heightens
the potential for what the domino effect
that you see there on the left
should it run into major liquidity
issues so we have banks that are failing
okay and maybe that should concern you
especially if you have money in in the
bank maybe you don't want to have too
much in there maybe you want to pull
your money out and put it in a minute
because you're probably going to be
safer you know in Argentina and what was
it 2001 they did what is known as El
corralito the Corral and nobody could
get their money out for several days and
when they went back uh their money was
worth one-third of what they put in one
third
okay that's how much it devalued and so
just keep those things in mind where
those uh poor countries teach us a
little lesson that we take uh into uh
the advanced countries because it could
happen there as well okay anyways here
we have uh Mr uh the same power there
um uh El Aryan and he says risks have
shifted from Financial to economic
contagion so now they're talking about
contingent looks like we have a virus
out there an economic virus okay and
what he says is this will play out
probably in the third and fourth quarter
and it will have a long tail that's what
he predicts he says there's gonna be
problems towards the end of the year or
second half of the year and just in case
here we have uh let me get this one out
um just we have this other news there
brace for the U.S economy to crash land
as the banking turmoil creates a credit
crunch Alliance says and what do they
say again uh the U.S economy is going to
crash land into a recession in the
second half of 2023 according to
Alliance and so yeah uh keep keep in
mind that some things might happen so
swiftly they don't give you time to
react okay and maybe you know everybody
knows what to do with their money I
guess you may not want to keep it in a
bank maybe under your pillow gold uh
diamonds whatever you want to maybe buy
oil from the Russians a cheap price
whatever but I can't yeah but maybe it's
not a good deal to have it in the banks
keep that in mind
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today after that little cheerful talk
yeah onto important stuff physics
okay existence what is existence and I
would say that it's probably the most
important word in physics together with
object thing what is a thing obviously
that's I mean if physics is the science
of that which exists then let's start
there right yeah and uh so uh let me put
it in the right perspective here okay
uh physics is the science of existence I
said that okay
Bob Dylan
physics only deals with that which
exists physics attempts to determine
what exists out there especially you
know the invisible intangible stuff the
mediators that mother nature uses to do
her daily work like gravity magnetism
light Etc religion is what studies
objects that don't exist really Concepts
that's what they are and there you have
a few examples the spirit you know is
that a subject matter of physics how
about space time
ghost black hole putting them all in the
same category how dare you yeah they're
all part of religion Black Hole
singularities uh soul wave functions
field heaven
yeah if Heaven is a field right yeah uh
energy Wormhole Dark Matter there you
see NASA's what space time they put a
fish net under the Earth and that's
never seen no fishnet under my Earth and
that's uh known or that's supposedly uh
physical interpretation or physical
representation of what time is uh you
know uh a fishnet is is that what time
is that what space time is so you can
see we have a little bit of problem with
using these Concepts as physical objects
and also the question is can we say that
those Concepts those things exist those
reified Concepts exist
yeah or is it valid to represent time
with a fishnet I mean does that make any
sense uh we represent love with a heart
went out with a liver or with my kidneys
okay is there any problem with that I
like my kid I love myself
okay so let's look at the definitions of
these words today we go to the
dictionary.com and this is what we find
so we want to find out what this word
means right existence the state or or
fact of existing oh I love that yeah but
the dictionary is full of those okay
being continuance in being or life life
okay so we look at existing we find
exist yeah yeah they say life is also
existed lives don't exist
I'll get to that but yeah uh so uh
existing okay what does exist it's a
verb and the question is whether it is
yeah that's about it
verb it's not a dynamic thing you don't
you don't do existing uh well this is an
adjective that's what it is it's a
quality of an object that's what it I'll
show that later on but my point is it's
not a dynamic verb like you don't do
something when you exist okay we can
have a cross-section in time it's a
state it's like you're it's like sitting
sitting is sitting a verb yeah it's a
state
you can see that guy's sitting but he's
not doing anything he's just yeah in a
certain position yeah so he's not doing
anything so what kind of verb is when
you don't do
that's the issue undo it and I'm doing
it
to have actual being to have life or
animation to live to continue to be or
to live you look a b and it says to
exist or to live being the fact of
existing existence something that exists
great we learned a lot existence is to
be and B is to exist and life what is
life the condition that distinguishes
organisms from inorganic objects and
dead organisms all they said is life is
the opposite of death or inert great so
we haven't learned much and opposite is
not a definition you know
antonym is not a definition okay so we
haven't learned much from dictionary.com
let's see if other sources are any
better and those are and these I really
love these are better here oh my God
here let me get this one
yeah yeah
give me a second here okay here it goes
okay existence this is the Wikipedia is
the ability
ability okay it's an ability of an
entity to interact with reality okay
reality being a synonym of existence
is different the ontological property of
being you look at being means the
existence of a thing so they use reality
which is a synonym of existence and
being which is a synonym of existence
but the funny part about Wikipedia is
that they reference
the Stanford encyclopedia philosophy
that's where they got their information
so we go there we find this article long
article and it's not worth even reading
because all you got to read is the last
paragraph there and you'll see the
sentence there it says existence remains
then itself a serious problem in
philosophy of language metaphysics and
logic and one connected to some of the
deepest and most important problems in
those areas after reading the whole
article you find out they have no idea
whatsoever what existence means all they
have are the theories or the arguments
proposed by different philosophers you
could call them ontologists over the
centuries that's all they have they have
no definition that you can sink your
teeth into and just in case you go to
the Catholic encyclopedia known as the
new advent okay and what do we find
there well we don't find the definition
of the word exist
at all the word doesn't exist
okay if you want to know something about
exist you got to go to the word god
and so they talk about the existence of
God and what are they talking about
there well there you see it theism the
belief
okay the belief in the existence of a
personal God and Atheism is the opposite
that this belief or non-belief or
however you want to state that so
they're talking about belief not about
existence
and they kind of equate that like saying
if you believe then I guess yeah
something like that
okay so we don't find anything from the
primary sources out there there are more
sources of course but uh what it shows
is that nobody has been able to define
the word exist in the last ten thousand
years and I just got the notion yeah
there is kind of close like how we know
what it means like there it is it's
there it's in reality it's doing it do
we know well that that's what that's
everyone's kind of circling the drain
but they don't know how to put their
finger on it okay so here are the
questions that I propose to get to the
bottom of it at least to eliminate what
existence is not about okay here it is
the first one uh is existence a an issue
of proof or belief
does existence apply only to living
beings I don't think anyone would say is
if that's true well uh except some
people's definition just now okay
can exist existence be used consistently
rationally scientifically you're saying
is the notion itself
uh inherently irrational or could it be
could it be or is there a definition
that can be used consistently when
you're actually being scientifically can
we use the word exist in science because
if we can't we can't say that physics is
the science of existence because we
can't Define existence I've told you
before I would say the word life is
inherently the notion of life is
inherently undefinable because everyone
has different cutoff points yeah
okay that's why we look at the universal
uh
the word that every living entity fits
that's the issue but that's another
that's topic for another day but here it
is okay let's go with belief and proof
uh belief is subjective
and so God says what's that you say that
my existence depends on your belief
you don't believe in God disappears
I mean that's that's actually something
that's brought up sometimes in these
theistic arguments where they say uh
whether God exists or not has nothing to
do with what I say or what you believe
hopefully not because for God they bring
that up imagine if I don't believe in
God that's coming in and out of reality
yeah yeah this appears suddenly I'm your
poor God I feel sorry for him anyways uh
that's one issue here's another one
existence depends on belief right
um you know and again that that takes
you to you know the the contradiction
there or the irrationality that God
disappears when you don't believe in him
you if you become an atheist suddenly
you know God disappeared poor fellow uh
evidence uh what evidence are you going
to produce for God or anything for that
matter you know here's a an example
right and that's got to do with the c
and touch you know is exists in
something that you can see and touch
well you know uh we have a problem with
that in here I showed this in the past
where you have the Klingon he's on the
other side of the universe he's got a
table and let's forget about the Klingon
himself which is also true you know
whether he exists but does a table exist
well I can't see I can't touch it I have
no way of ever seeing or touching it and
the question is does his table exist
you're saying there's we're making a
distinction between the fact that tables
can exist as as a category we know that
there there can be such things as tables
but the table that's there yeah the
specific one yeah the specific one and
no and then again uh the question is
um if we have to rely on C and touch
experiment observation that sort of
thing uh experiment uh Testing Lab
observation whatever you want to call it
we got a problem because that means the
asteroid doesn't exist until it touches
the moon I think most people or everyone
would agree that things it exist
regardless of whether we know about
their existence or not but there are a
lot of people there are some people
agree with that but yeah I think a lot I
think if you just said it like that
everyone would agree except the people
who go into these deep philosophical uh
tunnels like
rabbit holes they go straight into the
rabbit hole and then they start talking
about well if the tree falls in the
forest and no one's around here it
didn't fall at all and [__] like that
what is what does it make any sound yeah
what does an observer have to do with
something happening yeah again that's
why we eliminate the observer in science
in real science and genuine science we
eliminate the Observer no Observer
because we kill the witness we do the
mafia style but you do this what about
the machines where you put in the
observer in a place where there is none
or whatever an observer is not needed
not because you have to conceptualize
yeah yeah but that's just so that we
understand what we're talking about not
that there is a guy floating in space
looking at the asteroid we don't care
about that guy yeah
okay uh Next Issue says uh uh fellow
says existent he wrote this today that
existence is an endless series of events
so there's no place for a big bang hey
who said that but the issue here is that
is existence a series of events uh
hopefully not because what he's saying
is that existence is a dynamic concept
that's what he's saying that's the
underlying
because you make a distinction between
the or used as a uh explanation tool you
use a static universe but if you get
down to Brass tags there is no such
thing in reality everything is dynamic
yeah but uh that's why we have to stop
the universe because yeah but but that's
why this guy makes sense when he sends
existence is a series of events because
it is kind of hard yeah because it's
like saying okay my table hasn't moved
right it hasn't moved but everything in
the universe moved with respect to the
table Yeah
so the question is the table is
constantly moving with respect to every
atom in the universe in fact every atom
in the table is also moving etc etc but
the issue is
uh is is the table sitting inside my
room is that a movie
you know and you can say yeah it is a
movie because we're constantly moving
everything's moving in the universe but
that's not the point the point is we
have to stop the universe to
conceptualize certain things certain
things in this case existence which is a
static concept which can be can be right
um uh Illustrated or represented in a
single frame of the universal movie A
cross-section of time a cross-section of
motion
strange
explanation tool that you use but I
think it's very useful thing whenever we
talk it clarifies so much when you talk
about things like that but if you talk
about just reality if we're yeah we're
not talking about reality we're just if
if you we're just thinking about what
reality is there's no such thing as
stuff yeah because because the issue is
that uh people have their minds
wandering and they say well everything
in the universe are constantly moving
that's why we have to stop the universe
and step outside the universe or a
second together with God there and say
God please stop the universe and you
stop the universe and now you say okay
what does exist what exists in the
universe and at that point you say okay
this atom this atom this table this you
know because everything is in a
cross-section of time everything has
stopped like in the uh what is this
Twilight Zone uh episode where the guy
stops the entire universe that's kind of
like it should be so that you can see
now what are the objects there do you
think maybe calling them static and
dynamic Concepts like we understand what
we're talking about but if you think
about it that's kind of a misnomer okay
because you're giving a property to an
object property to a concept uh you
can't talk about a dynamic concept if
you think about it there's no such thing
as a dynamic a concept in motion yeah
obviously yeah in that sense
okay I'll let you figure out a name for
them I call him static and dynamic yeah
no I mean it makes sense yeah okay
anyways here it is let's go to the
second part being uh and living I mean
uh the does exist only
can is it circumscribed only to living
entities and you might say well of
course not you know but Descartes it I
think therefore I am
and that was a serious problem you know
here we have good old Descartes okay uh
put them up here of course all right so
I think therefore I am yeah he he was a
thinker like the famous thinker right
and I think he was thinking wrong he was
thinking wrong okay uh no uh I think his
reasoning was wrong because what he's
saying essentially he first he uses an
operational functional definition which
are
um irrational which are unscientific why
because the definition the definition
comes at the end of your presentation so
the whole presentation is about defining
the word at the end and that's not the
way Russian science science we Define
the word at the beginning and then we
know what we're talking about so that's
the way it should work and then the
question is Rock doesn't think so
doesn't exist I mean if Barack can't
think I guess it's only I think
therefore I exist I am right well an
offshoot of that some people would say
the rock doesn't exist until we look at
it
well yeah because we don't care yeah
again the question is uh does the rock
exist on the other side of the universe
in in the hands of the Klingon who's
throwing it right he's got something
there for him it exists it doesn't exist
for me but then we have a problem
because how can it exist for him and not
for me we have a problem is this a
question of observation of opinion uh
being in close proximity with the thing
I mean we don't have to go to the other
side of the universe we can go to the
other side of the earth I mean a Chinese
man on the other side of the earth he's
got a table I can't see it or touch it
does that table exist for him it exists
for me it doesn't exist
does that make any sense we were we have
a problem we have a contradiction that's
the issue the other issue is uh can you
begin to exist can you cease to exist
did Napoleon begin to exist I mean what
was it feet first Ah that's that's a
good question because if we're talking
about Consciousness now it gets weird
because yeah the question people don't
go in to come into Consciousness until
they're born so you could say that guy
didn't exist using the wrong way of
saying exists but he wasn't until he was
born
and the question is is it his soul his
yeah his conscious is that what exists
or began to exist or is it him the
physical body you know so so the
question can uh ultimately is can you
apply it to Concepts can you apply the
word existing Concepts in a rational
consistent manner that's going to be the
issue okay okay so let's continue here B
being again Dynamic concept uh being the
fact of existence of existing again it
shows you that they're used as synonyms
being be exist reality all those are
synonyms you can't use a synonym to
define a word so you know you can't use
it I mean you can but it doesn't make
anyone worse and uh again exists is a
static concept and this is how I prove
it show it
explain it are you meant it here it is
okay
um we can we don't need to have two uh
frames in a universal movie to
conceptualize exists what is this
Universal movie real quick okay the
universal movie it means that we take a
crush section like like we take a
snapshot of every single atom in the
universe 3D yeah we take a 3D snapshot
right of every atom in here is just
everything standing still nothing's
moving the next frame everything moves a
tiny amount whatever amount and so in
every frame of the film
three-dimensional film right we have
just photographs just a series of
photographs right so we look at a single
one of those photographs and there we
can say what exists in the you know what
atoms are there oh what else are there
are there chairs are there tables are
there the planets uh what what is in a
single frame of that movie well you're
assuming that all things that are in one
frame will not fall out in the next
frame they're just going to be somewhere
else you're assuming that in the next
frame there won't be new things that
were in the previous one they'll just
have moved yeah because if if you have
something either pop out of existence
cease to exist or come into existence
you have to show because that's okay to
to say it uh the the trick is to show me
the mechanism how God made
that thing to appear or disappear I mean
essentially what you're doing is saying
that in one case you're saying that
space turned into yeah nothing turned
into something and in the other case
nothing something turned into nothing
and you're gonna explain the process
well from one frame to the next well you
have different camps there's I mean
everyone who believes in big bang bang
and everyone who believes in God yeah as
as a physical thing not just a concept
yeah would say that it is possible for
nothing to become something and vice
versa yeah yeah no problem I have no
problem with that I just need the price
yeah but then that's black magic yeah
they believe in Black Men okay but then
we have to admit that that's if you
cannot explain the process you cannot
tell me the mechanism uh yeah you can
come up with anything you can also say
that Santa Claus exists you know for
that matter yeah yeah
okay and finally consistency can't use
exist consistent if applied to Concepts
that's what we're going to argue here
you're saying uh you can't a word exists
should remain for objects and not
Concepts strictly for raja's
circumscribed I guess I guess the only
reason anyone would say that a concept
exists is they're pinpointing
they're pinpoint I think this is what
philosophers say they're pinpointing a
pattern in reality a pattern which we've
seen exists and that is kind of where
they say for example all living things
need to eat does hunger exist
it becomes one of those things where
they extrapolate a concept a pattern
yeah but we can't answer and give that
existence we can't answer the question
because we don't know what the word
exists means
but that's what that's why they have a
difficulty defining it because they lump
everything into it that's one issue the
other one is they start with examples
but they never work their way back to a
definition well because they started the
example because it's because they don't
restrict it to only objects they also
say hunger exists angry they say love
exists that's the wrong word yeah and
that's that's the wrong word you're
using exists for too many things and
here here's uh the scientific way of
handling that okay uh in physics physics
is one of the Sciences in fact uh it's
the main science the main one
foundations of physics these are the
foundations uh proposed by Bill Gates a
fellow that I know of out there physics
attempts to explain how our universe
works first and foremost physics
requires an object in physics only
objects may be said to exist why well
you see here we go through the
definitions a little series here and
they lead us through the definition that
we're looking for object that which has
shape okay distance is the separation
between objects location is the set of
distances from one object to all the
others or whatever
subset that you look at and what is
existence an object that has location
object plus location
a concept what is that existence is a
concept right a word that embodies or
invokes two objects or two words treated
existence object plus location yeah
so now we can say that only if you uh
use object only if or let's put it in a
different way uh existence requires an
object you cannot have a concept such as
love and say that love exists or that
intelligence exists it's the wrong word
or or yeah because what are you saying
when you say that it exists are you
saying that you can touch it you see it
are you saying that it's out here uh
what is it the same thing
there are effects and patterns can have
been observed and when I talk about it
you know consequences yeah yeah but but
it comes into this weird realm of when I
say it you know what I'm talking about
so you've observed it too so is it in
reality but not in a physical way yeah
but then the question here is how can
you how can you make sense of that if if
you're gonna say that a table exists and
this table yeah people say okay I
understand what you mean by that I can
see it and touch it that's more or less
the idea we're saying it's not that you
can see your touch it's that it has
location it's an object has shame and it
has location now how do we relate to the
word to concept can we how we're how are
we gonna use the word for Concepts uh
does a headache exist well yeah I have a
headache so for me it exists yeah so
should we have a a a concept equivalent
for exist that isn't exist because
exists is the wrong word
that's for other people it doesn't
really make sense then everything would
make sense everything because I think
anyone at least makes the distinction
between something
an object having physical presence
and a concept being merely a pattern
that we've observed or there's at least
consequences there's some qualitative
difference between those two types of
existing that's one issue but the other
one is that they work off of examples
and of a a series of because it's got to
be dynamic you say well you know my
headache exists because it's an ongoing
pain but it's a good example this is my
right but what I'm getting at is is
until you go back and Define the word
exist in such a way that you can use it
consistently scientifically
scientifically right rationally that
means you cannot apply it to Concepts
until you can Define it in such a way
that you can in the body or include or
income that's why they can't define
exist that's why they can't determine it
all anytime you see a debate about
whether God exists or not yeah they go
off on these what just complete tangents
because they just don't get to the
bottom of it it's as simple as that
there are things that exist like
physical things I.E objects and there
are things that I don't want to use the
word exist flip flop those are the
concepts that exist the patterns that
we've observed that is where God and and
anger and hunger and love and all these
things fall under
that's why they have so many problems
with all this philosophy stuff they go
in circles
truth that's another one that drives me
crazy people talk about does truth the
truth exists like you're using the wrong
word exist is not the right word
okay let's move on here we have our
science critic and he's gonna talk about
uh predictions but he's gonna talk about
the accuracy of predictions let me put
this uh fellow on so he you know what
he's uh what his argument is here goes
listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include is guessing
which horse is going to win the race a
part of science
and if a prediction materializes does
that confirm the physical interpretation
of the phenomenon
with predictions it doesn't matter
whether it's a description or an
explanation the point of predictions is
to validate whether what you are testing
is accurate or not let's take weather
forecasting as an example let's say that
you've got two different models one says
that it's going to rain and the other
says that it's going to snow if it rains
then the ones that says that it's going
to rain is more accurate if it snows
then the one that says that it's going
to snow is more accurate and if it does
neither then you're probably going to
need a better model
okay so uh let's go through the rundown
now with what this file said uh he's got
so many things wrong it's hard to know
where to begin uh first thing uh
prediction is not an explanation okay
it's important to establish that because
um well I'll get to an example in a
second here prediction is a description
if I say that tomorrow there's going to
be an eclipse at two o'clock all I've
said is a description
I haven't explained why that's going to
happen
if I can explain why it's going to
happen I'm going to give you an
explanation I'm no longer talking about
the future I'm not talking about a
prediction I'm talking about the past
I'm talking about something I had
experience with uh
or some contact in the past with okay so
when as soon as you explain why a
prediction is going to come true you're
no longer talking about the future
that's why prediction just a prediction
just statement just a statement is
nothing but a description and that's
important but this one says well it's
neither we don't care about that etc etc
what does he say he says
um
uh accuracy he says uh
um it either snows or rains well we have
the difference between physics and math
now because physics is qualitative it
either rains or it snows okay it can't
can't be both okay so if it snows it
didn't rain if it rains it didn't snow
it's a black and white issue but this
fellow uh puts a a uh talks about
accuracy and so you know here here's a
an example for accuracy okay we're gonna
get a pencil can I do my famous
experiment million dollar experiment we
let go of the pencil and it falls to the
floor
now it either falls to the Florida that
don't it's one or the other it can't be
both okay so it either Falls or you
don't
this all says well we don't care about
that that black and white kind of stuff
yes or no no he cares about how fast
does it fall uh like what is the uh
um acceleration so he says 9.8 meters
per second Square well maybe it's 9.81
maybe it's 9.80 maybe it's 9.79 who
knows uh the point is he's talking about
accuracy which is an issue of
mathematics has nothing to do with
physics physics is just black and white
did it fall or not black or white did
the eclipse happen or not and the guy
says what happened to two two uh two
o'clock and one minute in the afternoon
like that's accuracy you know I can
predict exactly the moment as close as
they get and where's this like that's a
mathematical you're saying it's 100 or
an eight yeah so so so we have a
difference first between physics and
math that's one issue and we don't care
about math we we're talking about
physics here and then the other thing is
he says a model that predicts uh that's
just is a description because again if
if you're just going to predict you're
not going to tell me why and if you can
tell me why you're no longer predicting
now you're talking about the past about
something you already have experience
with
okay
okay let's go on to some of the
questions that people made since last
time uh and then we'll open the floor
for questions here okay go ahead no at
the end oh okay so let's go with the
first one don't forget it yeah it kept
in my head okay so Science is based on
faith oh [__] both religion and science
give us knowledge of the Unseen World
knowledge of the Unseen World okay all
knowledge of the Unseen World must be
based on faith
aha so science is a religion furthermore
each scientist has a different level of
Faith some believe in it more than
others thrown the words around a lot
yeah please candy so always don't care
about the words they use do they yeah
they don't so I got to show this all the
following science real science genuine
science is rational explanations
there's nothing about belief in there
okay belief is what comes out of
mathematical method you know the what
the mathematicians call science which is
not even that really not even that
uh-huh I mean belief doesn't even come
from math belief just comes from people
not knowing how to use science well
that's true but my point here is that
under that definition of rational
explanations there's no uh
uh provision for belief okay so that's
what science is science is just
explaining especially as it relates to
physics explaining phenomena you know
physical phenomena I mean science
doesn't really care about beliefs it
cares about assumptions and their
conclusions hopefully and belief is
totally in religion the problem is that
mathematicians talk about with proof
truth knowledge
they know or because they're trying to
attach it to reality so so the the chain
of command is something like there are
things we see in reality we would like
to explain it so we have to connect our
assumptions with things we've seen we're
not we're not answering questions of
things we haven't seen because we don't
care about those that that's the bottom
line we don't care No One's Gonna a kid
is gonna walk up and ask how two magnets
work because we've seen that happen in
reality he's not going to ask you about
things that he hasn't seen that he's
never experienced because that doesn't
make sense yeah but the issue here is
the following the mathematicians is not
just that they're trying to tell you
what they saw they really try to
convince you to believe in their Theory
and and that's when it gets uh really
bad because one thing is for you to
believe in the equation that they uh
were able to make an equation that
um describes what happened no problem
there we have no problem with that
that's that doesn't tell you uh the
explanation the physical interpretation
for what caused that event or that
phenomenon to happen that's where they
put in a lot of garbage a lot of
irrationality and they say we've proved
it what did you prove yeah Authority
also but what did you prove did you
prove that you know that that's uh time
has worked how did you prove that and to
whom did you yeah that's a big one
that's another it's been proven to him
it's like when people say we're
insignificant in the universe to whom
not to me I'm and again I'm significant
what they want to show is that they know
that they've proven because stop asking
questions
we know we know just memorize it but for
the test and you'll know it too don't
look at what's behind the curtain okay
uh another fellow says belief is a
destroyer of knowledge believing is
philosophical suicide thinking stops
we're believing begins belief is
accepting something is true without
evidence what it requires evidence uh so
he's saying that if we have evidence I
guess it goes beyond belief into
knowledge which at the bottom it says
it's just true justify true belief I
guess we're back to square one
so the only barrier the truth is
believing you already have it or that
truth is unobtainable our best route to
truth is the scientific method when we
know something it's not belief
aha it is fact and empirically correct
truth so this fellas going around in
circles going from belief to
announcements that's the process it goes
from belief to knowledge to truth to
fact to believe and the issue is you
know I mean uh all he's doing is chasing
his tail around I mean well are we
saying that belief is uh uh if you
believe something and he says without
evidence then it's just belief it
becomes I guess knowledge or truth when
you've gotten enough evidence yeah it
means that they commence you they
convinced but that's he's right he's
right yeah I mean he's right in the
sense that they convinced you that
doesn't mean that you have the truth
that is ours you believe something you
look for evidence you find evidence even
if it isn't I mean it's evidence to you
because that is what you review because
that's what proves it to you in
retrospect it becomes evidence yeah the
point here is that truth
knowledge proof is uh subjective what is
what do you believe what is evidence is
it not
by definition tool to convince yeah
that's what it is it doesn't mean that
you figured out how Mother Nature runs
her Universe it just means it just means
that whatever they showed you you
believe it because you have evidence
that is evidence for you so some person
says I have evidence that God exists
okay show me what the evidence is well
look at the flower who could have made
this except God you know and so they
come with these arguments and they say
we have evidence that God exists because
there's the evidence there's a flower
there's the bee running around who could
have done it if if not God you know it's
very conspiracy theory the way we talk I
guess and so is that truth they're
trying to convince you that China is
like yeah it sounds kind of crazy but
that is the process you might as well go
with the Body Snatchers the ETS who come
and take our bodies you know then you
then you believe
okay here's another phone he says I to
think is a concept and cannot be drawn
but you could prove pause the movie and
there would be something there that you
could point to okay so you're pointing
to a brain assuming you had every atom
or every cell in the brain in your hands
or or in front of you right that you can
see right they the Japanese has a group
right ready machine learning algorithm
training it to how to generate pictures
from brain scans it can essentially read
your mind with a crude interpretation of
whatever object you are thinking of
this experiment demonstrates that it is
indeed possible to imagine the images
that are appearing in the subject's head
we can make a movie of whatever objects
are appearing
okay so uh this all says that let's
assume you know uh we have all the atoms
in our brain every connection assuming
everything's connected by the
electromagnetic ropes and we have
electricity and magnetism and we also
have chemical reactions inside the brain
all that's going on in there right let's
say you had God's uh ability to see
super powerful right you can see inside
of brain you can see every atom in there
you you take a snapshot at some point
right a 3D snapshot one frame of the
universal movie of this guy's brain you
say okay that pattern uh I know it I
know it by my experience that's a dog
and more than that I can tell you that
specific pattern that Arrangement just
in that snapshot right is a uh
what is it um
police dog what is it uh
okay I'll use another Greyhound it's a
greyhound and he's great uh because I've
seen that pattern before and I recognize
that I identify it with a greyhound
great Greyhound dog okay so that's the
pattern for a dog another one could be
for a cat okay so this guy's thinking
about a dog okay okay that's if you
could see
[Music]
almost every atom in the brain and not
only that you would have to see also the
uh magnetic fields the electricity going
through the synapses uh you would have
to look at it yeah I mean yeah what is a
how does the brain work well you know
you have all these things that are
working together to create thought and
so the question is you know can you take
a cross-section of time of someone's
brain take a snapshot of that you know
God's camera right you take a snapshot
of where every atom is what every atom
is doing and doing is a big word because
again we're telling us about a snapshot
there is no doing there you just see a
pattern does it can you say that that
panel represents a dog that's what the
guy was thinking at that cross-section
of time they're saying that they did
not really it's uh it's like because
this is an ongoing thing where the guy
is thinking well yeah I don't think they
got it to the point where they say that
that they can see where every atom is
but they don't have to but again but you
don't have to someone can draw a picture
of a dog on a piece of paper I don't
have to know where every graphite thing
is on that piece of paper I get the gist
okay yeah you don't have to go to the
top but uh the question is yeah it can I
mean if you had the brain of Mother
Nature or God or whoever then maybe yes
if you knew where every adamant or a
universe was in fact LaPlace said that
to I think the Napoleon and he said you
know if if I could know where every atom
in the universe is in which direction
it's moving I could predict the future
because you know from there he can tell
you what the next step is but uh you
know that's that's reserved for God up
there not for us puny humans you know
there's I'm in a headache China yeah
456 hydrogen atom ah [__] It's already
moved so I don't think I don't think
we'll ever reach that level
anyways let's open up the Thor for a
question we have any questions there uh
people
many more just people uh I guess uh
continuing the the debate of what you're
talking about in on their own start off
with most people talking about how uh
omnivore we're probably always omnivores
yeah and again I think it's a matter of
degrees I think we were always omnivores
to some degree but we got the fangs uh
primarily I think because during maybe
two million years of our primary
Evolution we were primarily meat eaters
would you agree that
uh being a carnivore or being a
herbivore
would you say that
that all animals start as omnivores and
specialize into one of them like they
die into carnivores no I I look at it in
a different way uh and let's look at
them can a lion become a herbivore well
let me out of time let me tell you just
how I look at this when the Cretaceous
uh disappeared ended you know and we
started the the quaternary in the
tertiary and all these uh you know the
our era the era the mammals uh I think
what happened that you had all these
little mice rats uh squirrels like uh
animals that survived the Cretaceous
they were mammals and each one squatted
some kind of
um Niche and someone after the
um
veggies and someone after the meat I
think that's the way it was and he
specialized and because of that they
evolved differently the herbivores from
the carnivores I think that's the way it
was and I think that happened in every
era even if you go back to the Cambrian
you will see the same thing some
specialize in meat and others in veggies
uh uh have you ever defined the word
belief
uh no because belief is part of religion
and I don't do religion you know you
talk about belief a lot yeah because the
only reason I talk about belief is
because the mathematicians equate it uh
with in other words they they talk about
knowledge and we know that knowledge is
belief
it's that's what we know for a fact if
if something we know is that knowledge
is belief why because knowledge once you
have it means that uh you believe it
it's just a stronger belief that's all
it is a greater certitude that you know
for sure that something happened okay or
that something is
uh do you believe in the soul
so whatever that means do you are you
saying believe in the existence ah of
the Soul say the whole word
yeah cheating yeah yeah you're saying do
you believe in the existence of God well
imagine if I said do you believe in the
existence of this chair
and the question is if I don't believe
will I fall on my butt on the floor
because I don't believe in the chair
that's holding me I mean does it make
sense to say that I believe in the
existence of this chair if the soul is a
concept can is the question even valid
well you have to do because
we take your definition of concept of
existence then is asking whether love
exists even a valid question obviously
not right well no because immediately it
eliminates all Concepts so you cannot
you cannot say that a concept exists
because it's not a no a concept is a
relation between two objects made by a
human you know especially and so you
know when we have a concept you can't
say that a relation exists not in
science but you're welcome to Define
they can exist to embody or include
uh Concepts if someone did if we
accepted your definition and someone
asked does love exist it would be a hard
no by definition yeah because not like
not not an adjaded love doesn't exist
not like that no no it's by definition
it's very simple you say in ordinary
speech you can say that but you cannot
say that in science you cannot say that
love exists in science or intelligence
or data exists in science that's okay in
ordinary speech in the ordinary usage of
the word exists then you can say
whatever you want you can say God exists
also but when you come into science and
you want to talk in a rational manner
you have to begin by defining the word
exist if you're going to be using
talking about existence and for that you
can only include as I've shown only
objects you cannot include Concepts and
that's where people have problems
because they want to introduce their
religion into science
you know their opinions but okay that
leads me to my last question so this
one's kind of a tricky one a hard one to
see if I can build it
now in the comments I saw some people
talking about if you eat the brain of a
deer
you're laughing we're serious but that's
part of the question uh that you dream
what the deer live and assuming that's
true or not there's a lot of
I'm just going to use the word knowledge
there's a lot of things that we believe
in things we know that
it's I guess my question is why are
facts about reality so hard to like uh
get a get a grip on because it seems
like everyone has I mean there's
Homeopathy there's a lot of weird things
flat earthers there's your stuff there's
like it's all kind of lumped up in this
conspiracy stuff but why is this why are
conspiracy theories even a thing you
think that that facts and the truth
would eventually kind of clarify
themselves but these like it's like it's
like humans are never sure of things
well uh we start at the beginning uh why
did we invent Soul Spirits God and all
this other stuff to begin with we it's a
lot of reasons well I think one of the
main reasons there could be several
reasons but one of the main reasons is
that we could not see the mediators we
see things falling to the floor like a
pencil and we say why does it always
fall to the floor and so you know the
Greeks and everybody else they ask those
questions they say you know why is it so
and they could not see the mediators so
they said oh it's God it's the spirits
The Ghost and we invented all these
I mean I think that's one of the reasons
that we invented all these things and
mathematicians they use space time time
they and Fields and you say what is a
field what is energy what is space time
and they said well is this unseen this
Untouchable blah blah blah you know and
and again uh they get into all these
things because they can't see or touch
the mediator but even be honest I think
that's something I'm talking about even
simple things like nutrition there's so
much debate about simple things where
you just go shouldn't we have figured
some things out by now yeah and again I
think a lot of it has to do with
opinions in fact even among those who do
research you know you have one group
doing research another group doing
research some of them are you know just
doing it for a company that's paying for
their salaries okay so there's a lot of
that first of all but then a lot of
these groups they're honest they're
trying to do the best they can and they
have contrary uh results and so some
people say well I'm going to believe
group a and the other guy says I'm going
to believe Group B and so he says oh you
shouldn't eat carrots because it's bad
for your heart you know and the other
guy says something different and then
they say you say what the you know I
mean where do you get all these things
well it depends on who you read who you
believe that's all it is it's it's you
know it's just a big mess out there with
with belief and that's why physics tries
to stay away from belief and stick to
really that's how awesome what you can
rationalize and all science should work
like that not just physics like biology
and chemistry and should be objective
it's all just assumption based it's not
what do we believe it's like okay let's
just take this as an assumption does the
does it work yeah yeah one last thing uh
at some point we should build the our
set upside down so that when you throw
the pencil it goes up that'd be
hilarious oh yeah we can turn it off
yeah
and here's the tattoo how do you do that
we can do that with the magnets or
whatever that'd be awesome okay folks
then we'll see you again next week next